the recent covent surge taking a toll on
many local businesses including the
regional transportation commission which
is struggling with a shortage of bus
drivers mary jane belliesa joins us live
with what you need to know if you take
the bus to get around town
yeah you know bus leaders are
apologizing to passengers in advance for
these delays and you know unfortunately
rotc says that these shortages aren't
specific to certain bus routes as they
struggle to figure out what bus drivers
are available for what day
rtc deputy ceo francis julian says a
rise in omicron coveted cases is
responsible for its labor shortage
julian says rtc is working on short-term
mitigation strategies and service
changes to address these issues in the
meantime julian asks passengers to be
patient respectful and courteous to
drivers as they're pulling extra shifts
we have in between 50 and 80 operators
that are out either because because
they're quarantined out of caution or
because they contracted
covid so it is challenging our service
is
once again it's a fluid situation where
we're seeing disruption in between three
and six percent on a day-to-day basis
the rtc has posted open positions on its
website for drivers and mechanics
now this transit app can help you track
the bus routes bus wait times and what
delays to expect reporting live here at
the bonneville transit center mary jane
vallieza live local now